[MUSIC]
Hey, welcome back.
Have you ever wanted a framework
that comes with its own build tool,
will automatically generate and
maintain your apps file structure, and
keep your templates and data in sync?
Then you're probably looking for
something like Ember.
And we're now going to look
at an Ember framework.
As we go through this lesson,
I encourage you to work through
each of the steps yourself.
Building up the app along with me.
You'll learn a lot by watching me
work through building a project, but
you'll learn so
much more if you build it yourself.
Ember describes itself as a framework
for creating ambitious web applications
and boy does it help you
easily create ambitious apps.
It's an extremely powerful framework and
is powered sites for companies
like Netflix, Groupon, Discourse,
Twitch, Yahoo and even Microsoft.
So Ember will be able to handle
anything you could throw at it.
Ember enables you to create
powerful apps with ease
because it favors convention
over configuration.
You have to name and
organize your files a certain way.
Depending on the kind of file, you also
have to place it in a specific location
in the project's file structure.
At first, this might seem
daunting to maintain, but
using Ember's command line tool,
it couldn't be simpler.
Another benefit of this strict
app organization is that
every Ember apps structure is the same,
and developers new to your team
will be able to jump right in.
Doesn't Ember sound awesome?
Let's get going so
you can build your next project
with this powerful framework.